اشتباكات مدينه بليله تعيد الى الاذهان
جمله اذا من الاشتباكات القبليه شهدتها
مختلف ولايه دارفور في العامين الاخيرين
اسفرت عن سقوط مئه القتلى والجرحى فضلا عن
تسببها في موجه نزوح وصفت بالكبيره
في مدينه الجنينه بين رعاه ومزارعين بدات
بعراق بين شخصين وانتهت بسقوط 83
و160 الجريحه حسب علاجه الاطباء المركزي
السودانيه
18 من يناير وقعت اشتباكات في قريه الطويل
سعدون بين قبيله ترزيقات وقبيله الثلاثه
او قاعه 60 قتيلا وعشرات الجرحى وفي ثامن
من ديسمبر من عام 2020 شهدت منطقه
اشتباكات بين مزارعين ورعاه راح ضحيتها
نحو 88
وفقا للججه اطباء ولايه غربارفور في
السابعه عشر من يوليو 2021 سقطت 12 قتيلا
و16جريحا في اشتباكات قبليه في كرنك وجبل
مون بغرب دارفور وفقا للجنه اطباء ولايه
غربي دارفور المنطقه نفسها شهدت في الثامن
من مارس الماضي شبكات بين قبيله المثليت
والقبائل العربيه في منطقه جبل مون في غرب
دافور اسفرت عن 16 قتيله هذه الاشتباكات
بين قبيلتي رزيقات والمساليب تجددت في
الخامس من ابريل الماضي في منطقه الواقعه
غرب المدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غربي
شخصا من قبيله القمر في اشتباكات مع قبيله
الرزقات في محليه في